let's try and unpack this right I'm
gonna do it we did half size we did 1/3
size
I wonder if you can think back to when I
gave you the coastline paradox I'm gonna
try this way 1/3 sighs okay now hold on
a second when you just take a line right
if you divide it up into thirds into
thirds
you should get three of them right if on
the other hand I took a square a
two-dimensional object if you divide it
into the third chunks you should get
nine of them right okay watch we
actually did this before what portion of
this cost curve part of the snowflake
what portion of it is a third remember
how I am said look all of these little
cubes right it's half the height usually
half with half the depth what's a third
here yeah just horizontally across right
do you agree with that like this this is
because that distance is exactly the
same as this distance and this distance
there's three of them I've divided up
into a third right but then a problem
emerges and we did this before with the
coastline when we start counting when I
start thinking how many of these things
are my god
I did three of them no the wrong are
there nine of them no let's count ready
okay I did the first one is one okay the
easiest other one this one is this one
over here could symmetrical there's two
okay now what do we have up in here
right when you go at an angle there are
two of them and then there's this other
one here there are four hold on a second
let me just write this down a
- this is scheme that I've got here
right I have I have four objects that
are a third the size objects size right
I don't have three I don't have nine
definitely doing at 27 okay so where
does the dimension come into this how
can I use this to calculate the
dimension right have a look at which
number in each time we went through one
dimensional two dimensional three
dimensional have a look at where the
dimension appeared right with the way
the dimension of here here you see that
it's that power one then it appeared
here - and it appeared here three and
then you told me if we had a four
dimensional thing they call it a
hypercube by the way it would be four
okay it would be three to the power of
something 3 to the power of something
hold on a second for us not a nice lead
power of three right when we're trying
to solve something we don't do nerd
mathematicians tend to give it a name
right so this some number you have three
the power of that number you get four
right if you get three the power to you
get nine you get three times three yeah
27 three times some other number gives
you four now you have a calculator there
right I'm gonna teach you how to get
this exactly in a second but you don't
need to get it exactly to know roughly
where the number is it's clearly between
1 and 2 do you agree with that right try
some numbers put in some decimal places
in there one and a half one and a
quarter give it a go give me good see
how see how close you can get when you
do 3 to the power of something equals 4
how close can you get to 4
it's just not everyone's number so
that's one can anyone get within who can
get within one decimal place you can get
three point nine or four point one hands
up yeah we've got a few can anyone get
within two decimal places
can anyone get like um three point nine
nine well four point oh one can they
don't get that close
pretty close I'm pretty closely okay
let's see um Ryan what was your number
4x wait no what was younger 4x the power
to six five okay and you got full point
zero one zero one did anyone get closer
than that yeah what'd you get okay what
was your palate Estep two six one nine
two six okay right now we can play this
game for a while right clearly this is
the better way of doing this but before
we just move on can I just conclude what
you just did we know what
one-dimensional objects are and
two-dimensional objects you are some
loud telling me that this object is
neither one nor two dimensional it's got
a fractional dimension what's up with
that
okay now let's work out what this actual
number is this is sort of um spoilers a
little bit this is something we're going
to be covering you're going to be
covering later okay
see how this is a equation in index form
okay it's an equation in UNIX for this
is not an easy problem to solve when
you're just punching your numbers right
so we will rewrite this in a totally
different form we write it like this if
you make X the subject right we
introduce this thing called a logarithm
some of you might have heard this word
before
you write it like this and I'll tell you
what it means okay
that's write out X equals log base 3 o 4
let me try and explain what that means
because you'll get it in more detail
later I just want to introduce to you ok
base 3 that's the base over here right
4 that's the number you're trying to get
to ok so it's like 3 raised to some
power gives you 4 it's about one point
two six one nine ok now how you do that
in your calculator what you need to
punch into your calculator because you
have a log but there is punch this in
log four divided by log 3 okay can you
do that what number do you get you
should get a whole bunch of decimal
places when you do log 4 divided by log
3 what are you getting one point
welcome to 6 one day five eight so we
can see why Willie was so close right
we're they've had one point two six one
nine that's within the ten hundred
thousand ten thousandth of a unit right
that's why he was able to get so close
right yeah do they have this like
something this you mean that number yeah
it's the name has is always three or
four that's that's its name okay um
sir what have we just established right
this is a factor right uh it looks like
a wine right like I drew it I drew the
whole thing without picking up my markup
right it takes up space in two
dimensions kind of but when you crunch
the numbers in this scheme of measuring
dimensions you get something else out
now all French or fractals do this
remember this time
you remember this one
what was he called son of Mines this is
the Capt triangle right now with that
drawing it all over again
right you can see it's in some of you
have in your book okay
can we do this same process can we do
this same process what size have I
divided up what size is the fractal
getting smaller but think about for
example this is a new copy this one here
that's a new copy a smaller copy of the
whole fractal right one half how far you
know
think carefully I think this is width of
the new small triangle is exactly a half
the width of the big frame cuz look I've
got two of them right there so it must
be a huh right how many such half sized
objects do I have in Cu Pinsky's
triangle and the answer is I've got one
there I've got another one here
okay so I have four this guy I'm running
out of space on the graph here I have
three objects that are what sides
they're hot sighs okay now going through
the same process what I want is two to
the power of some number should give me
three now going back through even if you
don't fully understand what's happening
here
right but where you get X is you say
it's log base 2 of 3 which in your
calculator is log 3 / long - what is
this number one point five ish right
again it looks kind of like a
two-dimensional object but it's not
really right it's like a a one and a
half dimensional object okay so when we
have a look at dimension
right what you are now breaking apart is
this idea of fractal dimensions okay